[Musique]
mehdi ben hamad est un exemple de
métissage réussi
[Musique]
originaire du maroc mehdi ben hamad est
arrivé avec sa famille à granby à l'âge
de 8 ans et à quelque chose aussi
je me sens peut-être plus confortable
d'explorer ici évidemment au maroc
chambre c'est sûr qu'ils aient un peu
plus de de réticences c'est juste que on
aura quelque chose de physique qui se
passe chaque fois que j'arrive là boys à
quelque chose où est mon corps
communiquent très facilement puis
naturellement avec l'endroit pour y
tenir aux sonorités moyen-orientale il
mélange de l'électro et des influences
viennent occidental il chante en
français puis en anglais et en dari déjà
parlé au maroc le maroc il ya quelque
chose qui n'est pas nourri la pop ici a
calé un petit quelque chose aussi qui
manquent donc j'ai dû créer un peu c'est
une varlope où j'étais entièrement mois
où j'avais comme tout toutes mes
facettes qui cohabiter ensemble et je
pense que ce qui est un jardin secret au
début est devenu un grand univers dans
lequel tout le monde peut se plonger
visuellement il détourne des symboles
traditionnels pour leur insuffler une
grande modernité
il navigue avec fluidité et avec grâce
autre symbole masculin et féminin
je pense ça s'est fait naturellement
j'ai tout le temps été attiré vers ce
qu'il dit plus féminin entre guillemets
et c'est toujours une manière très
instinctive et naturel une liberté qui
peut choquer récemment interviewé par un
populaire site web marocain les
réactions étaient vives pour le meilleur
mais aussi pour le pire la réception si
c'est pas c'est pas nécessairement la
même au maroc je pense que les gens
soient un petit peu plus un peu plus
choqué c'est peu flipper avant la
polémique simplement pour une pause que
je vais prendre même pas pour quelque
chose que je porte même si je pige pas
de rouge à lèvres vernis
ses oeuvres sont exposées à montréal au
hangar 77 sur la rue bernard dans cateau
mont royal jusqu'à la fin septembre il
sera en concert le 22 ou dans le cadre
du festival mode et design
mehdi ben hamad un artiste singulier qui
fait bouger les lignes ici n'est dit
alexandre chartier radio canada montréal
[Musique]